the tools belong to the cockerel endures
tarter Tao was current in the islands
it's just that colonialism had wiped it
out there's not anyone else here doing a
traditional
the revival here started out from tattoo
machine the machine is not connected to
the old ways so I think that gap is vast
for an outsider to stand up in their air
can hold the tools up it can be
challenging I have a lung condition and
something that I'm born with it's not
something that I contracted and it's
also something that you can't catch
cystic fibrosis is the name for me it's
personally been a helping hand you know
it's been something that's I felt like
made me engage in life
what makes Mapo a good student he
carries the tools well he takes
responsibility very serious I think the
importance of teaching you know and
having the apprentice you know what we
do is something that's been done for a
really long time the actor now sharing
that with mobile confirms them the
responsibility of the tools is an
important one
because the tools the designs they don't
belong to me and it's something that's
been passed down so it's my
responsibility to ensure they're in safe
hands
it's like being a caretaker I've been
caretaker of everything known it's like
using it with love and passion and
respect
you